Si tu fais tourner une balle autour d'un axe puis d'un autre, ce n'est pas la même chose que de faire les deux rotations dans l'ordre inverse.
Aujourd'hui dans Qiskit in the classroom, on va voir ce que cette balle a à voir avec les ordinateurs quantiques et l'un des principes les plus célèbres
de la mécanique quantique : le principe d'incertitude.
Bienvenue dans Qiskit in the classroom, une série de vidéos où on décompose un concept fondamental que tu pourrais
rencontrer dans un cours lié à l'informatique quantique. Chaque vidéo est accompagnée d'un module interactif lié dans la
description ci-dessous, alors n'hésite pas à y jeter un œil. Aujourd'hui, on parle du principe d'incertitude de Heisenberg. Si
tu en as déjà entendu parler, tu as peut-être aussi entendu la vieille blague sur Heisenberg : un jour, il s'est fait arrêter au volant et le policier lui a demandé :
« Tu sais à quelle vitesse tu roulais ? » Heisenberg a répondu : « Non, mais je sais exactement où je suis. » C'est en quelque sorte
le principe d'incertitude de Heisenberg en résumé : tu ne peux pas connaître simultanément la position et la quantité de mouvement d'une particule
avec une précision parfaite. On l'écrit souvent comme ça : Delta x * Delta p est supérieur ou égal
à ħ/2, où Delta X et Delta P sont les
incertitudes sur la position et la quantité de mouvement, et ħ est une minuscule constante fondamentale de la mécanique quantique.
Heisenberg a formulé cette inégalité en 1927 en imaginant comment mesurer la position d'un électron. Si
tu faisais rebondir un photon dessus pour voir où il est, ce photon donnerait inévitablement un coup à l'électron et perturberait sa
quantité de mouvement. Ce n'est pas qu'une déclaration sur les mesures qui perturbent un système : cela nous dit qu'il y a des limites fondamentales
à ce qu'on peut apprendre sur la nature. C'est un exemple d'un principe plus large appelé complémentarité, qui
dit que certains aspects de la nature sont incompatibles les uns avec les autres et ne peuvent pas être observés
simultanément. Par exemple, les objets quantiques se comportent parfois comme des particules et parfois comme des ondes,
mais on ne peut pas observer les deux comportements simultanément. La relation position-quantité de mouvement de Heisenberg ne couvrait qu'une
des nombreuses paires de caractéristiques complémentaires. Cette incertitude inhérente est liée à la façon dont on voit les propriétés comme
la position et la quantité de mouvement en mécanique quantique. Au lieu de penser à X et P comme des variables ou des propriétés intrinsèques
que chaque particule possède, en mécanique quantique, la position et la quantité de mouvement sont des opérateurs. Ce ne sont pas des propriétés d'un
système, mais des choses qu'on peut faire à un système. Apprendre la position d'une particule maintenant nécessite de réaliser une
opération sur ce système et d'effectuer une mesure. Cette opération pourrait affecter le résultat d'autres opérations
ultérieures. Par analogie, pense à un morceau de bois sec. Il a de nombreuses propriétés, comme sa
position, sa taille, sa forme. Il a aussi la propriété d'être combustible et de flotter dans l'eau. Si ce bois était un
objet quantique, ces propriétés ne seraient pas celles qu'on pourrait simplement connaître a priori. On dirait plutôt que ce sont des
observables — des choses qu'on peut apprendre sur le système si on réalise une opération dessus. Il faudrait donc appliquer les opérateurs de
combustibilité ou de flottabilité, ce qui nécessiterait d'essayer réellement de brûler le bois ou de le mettre dans
l'eau pour voir s'il flotte. Or, le résultat de chacun de ces opérateurs dépend de l'ordre dans lequel on les applique. Si
on teste d'abord la combustibilité, le bois brûlera en cendres et on ne pourra pas tester s'il flotte. Mais si on teste
la flottabilité en premier, il sera trop mouillé pour brûler. On dit que les opérateurs de combustibilité et de
flottabilité ne commutent pas — l'ordre des opérations compte. Cela conduit à une limite fondamentale
à la précision avec laquelle ces deux observables peuvent être connues pour le morceau de bois, puisqu'on ne peut pas dire avec certitude s'il est
combustible ou flottable sans connaître le contexte de cette mesure. Bien sûr, avec un vrai morceau de bois, tu pourrais
le couper en deux et tester les deux propriétés simultanément. Mais tu ne peux pas faire quelque chose comme ça avec une particule quantique.
Cette analogie avec le bois n'est que ça — une analogie. L'incertitude est une chose uniquement quantique. X et P ne commutent pas non plus,
et cette propriété de non-commutativité est ce qui conduit au principe d'incertitude de Heisenberg. En général, deux opérateurs quelconques
qui ne commutent pas auront leur propre principe d'incertitude. La forme générale du principe d'incertitude peut être
écrite comme ceci : Delta A * Delta
B est supérieur ou égal à
1/2 fois il y a A et B, où
ce crochet est appelé le
commutateur, et cela est égal à la différence entre appliquer d'abord A puis
B, et appliquer d'abord B puis A. Ces crochets angulaires
ici indiquent qu'on prend ce qu'on appelle la valeur d'expectation de ce qui est à l'intérieur. En gros, si tu effectuais la même
mesure de très nombreuses fois, la valeur d'expectation est la valeur moyenne de toutes ces mesures. Aujourd'hui, on va
réellement tester et vérifier ce principe d'incertitude sur un ordinateur quantique IBM. On va regarder trois différents
observables d'un qubit, montrer que leurs opérateurs ne commutent pas, et finalement on sera capables de prouver que le
principe d'incertitude est valable pour ces observables de qubit. Commençons par une brève parenthèse sur une façon utile de visualiser l'état quantique
d'un qubit. Il peut être représenté par un vecteur pointant quelque part sur une sphère appelée la sphère de Bloch. J'en ai parlé
dans une vidéo précédente liée dans la description, mais je vais te donner un bref résumé ici aussi. Voici la
sphère de Bloch. Chaque vecteur est paramétré par deux angles, Theta et F.
L'état zéro est au pôle Nord et l'état un est au pôle Sud, et une superposition égale de 0 et de 1 se trouve
quelque part le long de l'équateur, où F est égal à la phase relative entre les deux parties de la
superposition. Donc cet état ici serait égal
à 1/√2 |0⟩ + e^(iφ) |1⟩, où I est cette
phase. Lorsqu'on mesure un observable du qubit, le résultat est toujours l'une de deux options correspondant aux deux
états possibles du qubit. Pour l'expérience qu'on va faire, on va regarder trois observables et
leurs opérateurs correspondants X, Y et Z. Quand tu mesures l'un de ces observables, tu obtiens soit plus un soit
moins un, avec une probabilité pour chacun qui dépend de l'angle entre le vecteur du qubit sur la sphère de Bloch et
l'axe de mesure. Comme tu pourrais t'y attendre, Z mesure selon l'axe Z, X selon X
et Y selon Y. Rappelle-toi maintenant qu'on parle d'observables, parce qu'avec un système
quantique on ne peut plus simplement connaître des choses sur le système sans les mesurer.
Et chaque observable a une opération correspondante, car les mesures nécessitent des opérations. Ce n'est peut-être pas évident, mais
il s'avère que les opérateurs correspondant à chacun de ces observables X, Y et Z sont
des rotations de Pi autour de leurs axes respectifs. Donc X est une rotation autour de X, Y
autour de Y, et Z autour de Z. Pour voir si ces opérateurs commutent ou non, on peut vérifier si les rotations
sur une sphère commutent. Si c'est le cas, le principe d'incertitude ne s'appliquera pas et on pourrait connaître X, Y et Z d'un qubit
avec une précision parfaite. Si elles ne commutent pas, on sera capables de trouver une nouvelle relation d'incertitude pour le qubit. Regarde
le point sur cette balle lorsque je tourne d'abord autour de X puis autour de Y. Il finit
ici. Maintenant, essayons dans l'ordre inverse : je tourne d'abord autour de Y puis
autour de X. Il finit là-bas. Donc elles ne commutent définitivement pas. Cela signifie
qu'on ne peut pas connaître simultanément les valeurs exactes X, Y et Z d'un qubit. On aura une
relation d'incertitude. On va passer sur les détails ici, mais on obtient trois relations d'incertitude différentes.
On a donc Delta X * Delta Y
est supérieur ou égal à ⟨Z⟩, Delta Y * Delta Z est supérieur ou
égal à ⟨X⟩, et Delta Z * Delta X est supérieur ou égal
à ⟨Y⟩. Donc le produit de deux de ces incertitudes quelconques est toujours supérieur ou
égal à la valeur d'expectation du troisième observable. Utilisons Qiskit pour voir ce qui
se passe quand on essaie de mesurer à la fois Z et X de l'état zéro. Mesurer Z est facile — c'est la base dite standard
de l'ordinateur quantique : les mesures se font toujours selon Z par défaut. Mais pour mesurer X, on doit effectuer ce qu'on appelle un
changement de base — essentiellement faire pivoter la sphère de Bloch pour que X pointe maintenant vers le haut là où Z pointait avant. Pour ce faire,
on utilise un gate Hadamard. Le circuit quantique complet ressemblera donc à ceci : on mesure selon Z, on applique le Hadamard,
puis on mesure selon X. Si on utilise la primitive Qiskit sampler pour exécuter cette expérience de nombreuses fois, on obtient
un histogramme de résultats de mesure qui ressemble à ceci pour la mesure
en Z, et comme ceci pour la mesure en X. Comme tu peux le voir, on a mesuré le
qubit dans l'état zéro selon Z avec une certitude proche de 100 %, mais
selon X, on ne savait pratiquement rien sur l'état du qubit : il a été mesuré soit zéro soit un avec une probabilité égale,
ce qui signifie que notre incertitude en X était aussi grande que possible. Cela nous donne
une idée de ce compromis d'incertitudes, mais on peut faire un peu mieux sur notre ordinateur quantique. On peut utiliser une
primitive Qiskit appelée estimator pour trouver les valeurs d'expectation de nos observables X, Y et Z et l'
incertitude de chacun. Essayons pour l'état pointant dans la direction X+ sur la sphère de Bloch. On utilisera estimator
pour calculer les incertitudes en X et en Z pour cet état, et la valeur d'expectation de
Y. Avec cet état, on obtient ce résultat de Qiskit. Quand on prend le produit des deux
incertitudes en X et Y, on voit que, comme attendu, c'est plus grand que la valeur absolue
de la valeur d'expectation de Y. Mais c'était juste pour un état particulier. On veut s'assurer que cette inégalité
est vraie pour tous les états de qubit. Utilisons donc estimator à nouveau, mais cette fois on va lui demander de balayer les valeurs d'un
paramètre et de trouver les valeurs d'expectation à chaque valeur de paramètre qu'on lui donne. Ici, le paramètre qu'on veut
balayer est l'angle Theta sur la sphère de Bloch, afin de vérifier l'inégalité pour tous les états de qubit qui se trouvent sur
cet arc qui coupe le plan XZ. Quand on fait ça, on obtient un graphique en fonction de l'angle Theta. La courbe rouge
est le produit des deux incertitudes et la courbe orange est la valeur d'expectation de Y. Comme attendu,
le produit des incertitudes en X et Z est bien plus élevé que la valeur d'expectation de Y. Mais ce n'était
pas trop difficile à satisfaire l'inégalité, car la valeur d'expectation de Y était si faible — elle était nulle pour tous les états sur
cet arc. Faisons un balayage similaire à travers les valeurs de Theta, mais au lieu de balayer dans le plan XZ, on va mettre φ égal à π/
4. On regarde donc les états de qubit qui se trouvent sur un arc différent sur la sphère. Ici, on voit que l'inégalité est
testée un peu plus, puisque la courbe orange et la courbe rouge sont plus proches l'une de l'autre. Mais le rouge est toujours au-dessus de l'orange
et le principe d'incertitude tient toujours. On n'a pas encore vérifié tous les états, mais j'espère que tu commences à saisir
l'idée. Il y a une inconnaissabilité fondamentale de deux aspects complémentaires quelconques d'un système
quantique, y compris ce qubit qu'on a utilisé. Le principe d'incertitude nous force à admettre que peu importe
combien on essaie, peu importe à quel point nos mesures sont ingénieuses, on ne saura jamais tout avec une précision parfaite.
Il n'y a pas moyen d'y échapper, vraiment. Si tu ne me crois pas — ou même si tu me crois — je te lance le défi : va consulter le module
lié dans la description et essaie de battre le principe d'incertitude. Merci d'avoir regardé et à la prochaine !